Mit Haustieren können wir Erinnerungen sammeln,
die uns ein Leben lang begleiten.
Der 99-jährige Ron Grantham erinnert sich
zum Beispiel immer noch an seinen Hund Spot,
den er in jüngeren Jahren immer zum Fischen
mitnahm.
Erinnerungen wach zu rufen aus denen sich
neue Gespräche und Interaktionen entwickeln
gehört zu den Aufgaben von Roboter-Hund Biscuit.
Er ist einer der Bewohner des Pflegeheims
South Care im südenglischen Burnmouth.
"Unsere Bewohner lieben ihn einfach.
Und er macht süchtig, man hört einfach nicht auf ihn zu streicheln, obwohl er kein echter Hund
ist."
erzählt Deanna Barnes, die Managerin der
Einrichtung.
"Sie werden einfach aktiver.
Wenn sie im Sessel sitzen und gerade ein bisschen
dösen, dann werden sie sofort wach, wenn
sie den Hund hören und nehmen Kontakt zu
ihm auf."
Besonders Bewohnern mit Demenz hilft der Hund
dabei sich zu entspannen, sich zu erinnern,
und am Leben in der Einrichtung teilzunehmen.
Noch sind Roboter-Hunde zu Therapiezwecken
in Großbritannien nicht üblich.
In Japan hingegen sind Hunde wie Biscuit schon
lange ein Hit.